the caterham 620r is not for the  faint-hearted on a powerful weight ratio  it exceeds their so much aren t 1  against they won  there is no traction control there are  no driver aids well actually that's not  entirely true because this particular  620r comes with one very special  optional extra Kamui Kobayashi caterham  f1 driver he's going to show you what  this thing can do  haha  competing is getting it stopped  the engine just sounds twinkle  terms of what it can feel like to pay  with the formula 1 car well I mean [ __ ]  no man of course I think a much faster a  lot of town for there's no down force  actually but you know this car has a lot  of emotional stuff the emotion i'm  feeling